Blue Bloods is a ratings Powerhouse for
CBS but some of the show's 9 million
average weekly Watchers are speaking out
about the rapid decline of a fan
favorite character here's why
no TV show is perfect especially if it's
been on the air for 10 plus Seasons plot
holes and logic gaps tend to form irking
eagle-eyed fans popular characters are
diminished or just get annoying after
being mishandled in the writer's room
that's evidently the case with cbs's
police procedural Blue Bloods right now
as some fans are clearly fed up with one
character in particular husband and wife
cop team officer Jamie Reagan played by
Will Estes and officer edit Eddie Janko
Reagan played by Vanessa Ray work well
together as partners on the force
largely because of their differences
while Jamie is even tempered and
gentle-hearted Eddie is passionate with
strong opinions this contrast helps them
balance each other out in their
progressing relationship as well as on
patrol as part of the New York City
Police Department Ray joined the series
in the fourth season and was instantly
attracted to the character's personality
she told nerds of color in 2021 she was
eager messy and flawed I mean who
wouldn't love Eddie Eddie isn't perfect
but her honesty brings a different and
welcome energy to the long run learning
family police drama however some Blue
Bloods fans are definitely not happy
with her personality as of late in the
recent season 13 episode past history
Eddie tries to play matchmaker with
assistant district attorney Aaron Reagan
who is Eddie's sister-in-law and Aaron's
criminal defense attorney ex-husband
Jack Boyle during a case this storyline
didn't exactly sit well with long time
viewers so you're helping out defense
attorneys now yeah aren't you supposed
to be on the prosecutor's side some fans
felt Eddie overstepped her boundaries
with the Reagan family overall
especially its Police Commissioner
patriarch Frank Reagan one viewer
tweeted Eddie crossed so many lines
she's gonna need to talk to Frank too
yes Eddie wants her sister-in-law to be
happy but she's clearly inserting
herself into Aaron's private business
when she has no right to also Eddie had
a similar conversation with Aaron years
ago about Jack so why would she try this
tact again one fan noted this on the
Blue Bloods subreddit writing Aaron and
Eddie's Behavior was in character but I
thought Eddie recruiting Jack for the
purpose of getting him and Aaron back
together was stupid fans generally seem
fed up with Eddie and how recent scripts
treat her character an issue that
especially pops up in the later Seasons
another fan on Reddit posted why do they
write Eddie as so immature she is a
grown woman near 40 and they have her
talk and act like a naive teenager
sometimes I want to work wherever you
work buddy we can't work together a
whole career why not another fan noticed
something similar posting on Twitter why
has Blue Bloods made the Eddie character
so difficult lately in the season 13
episode first blush Eddie not only
lashes out at her husband over his
transfer to another Precinct she mouths
off at her Superior officer too the user
wondered if the show's writers were
trying to make the character unlikable
on purpose before being on the receiving
end of so much criticism Vanessa Ray
said she admires her character's
strength and resourcefulness she told
nerds of color in 2021. I hope that
Eddie showcases that gut instinct that
women have the Deep knowing that forces
us into action Blue Bloods is currently
the fourth most watched show on
broadcast television according to
deadline fans can chart Eddie's
Evolution or Devolution Fridays at 10 9
Central on CBS
[Music]